before i became a qualified architect i
actually used to own my own
drone company if that doesn't make me
qualified to
make this video today i don't know what
does
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about drones and
drones for architects
which one is the best for you and your
business now i used to own a lot of
drones there used to be a couple just
sitting in my cupboard collecting dust
others would get flown daily i've tried
almost
every single one on the market from a
friend from a supplier or either by
purchasing it myself
so when it comes down to these
recommendations i know what i'm talking
about
personally speaking dji makes the
absolute best drones to fly from a
consumer
and professional level the drones are
just so easy to fly so i'm going to
stick to the dji category
now i'm going to start with the most
expensive and best drone the dji phantom
4.
now this isn't my recommendation for a
very simple reason which i'll get to in
a minute
the dji phantom 4 is a phenomenal drone
it weighs about 1.4 kilos with all the
batteries in
and gives you about 30 minutes of flight
time 30 minutes
is pretty good as an architect because
we aren't going out
flying for kilometers and kilometers and
trying to get
those beautiful cinematic shots most of
the time we're just trying to get
those final details of the house trying
to get some good
photos for social media or potentially
you might be using that drone
as an inspection tool so most of the
time we don't need it to last
forever 30 minutes is absolutely fine it
operates in the zero to 40 degree
category
so in australia that's absolutely fine
except in summer we do exceed 40 degrees
every so often
having said that 40 degrees one or two
days in a year
isn't too bad so this drone operates
absolutely fine the camera is phenomenal
of course
with a cinematic one-inch sensor on it
it gives you full
cinematic quality files so you can edit
and color grade however you need to
and it gives you crystal clear photos
now the reason i'm not recommending
the dji phantom 4 and i'm not
recommending the next one either you're
going to have to stick around to the end
to find out what my recommendation is
is for the simple fact most countries
around the world including australia
have a law that states any drone over
250 grams must be flown
by a registered drone pilot in australia
that means you have to go
to your local airport and do a drone
pilot's license test an exam that runs
for a couple days it costs a
couple thousand dollars as a commercial
license
now if you're running this as your
average consumer you're more than
welcome to purchase
any of these drones but going back to
the new laws as
architects if you're flying it in your
business or for your business
then you are flying it commercially
which means you need a commercial remote
pilot license and basically you
know everything about air traffic safety
it is a very intensive course and it
isn't something to be taken
light-heartedly now if you aren't flying
this under a commercial license and you
are using
it as your average consumer and just the
general public
not under your architect's brand but
probably still going to use it
as an architectural drone well then
you're probably
best looking at the mavic air 2. now i
selected the mavic air 2
over the mavic pro 2 because it's very
simple at the end of the day
the mavic air is a simple small package
that is
perfect for all levels of production it
doesn't matter if you're starting out as
an architect
or if you have a fully fledged
multi-national business
because the mavic air 2's quality is
phenomenal in that size package
you can go almost anywhere with that
drone in your pocket
or just in your hand no questions asked
it is
phenomenal the mavic pro 2 is a step
above the mavic air 2
but in my personal opinion as an
all-around drone i do believe
the air 2 is just a much better product
in a much smaller form factor
if you are looking for those cinematic
quality files that you can color grade
with commercial grade color grades
then you're going to have to move to the
mavic pro 2 not the mavic air 2.
for the simple fact that it has better
color grading software
and image files at the end of the day
versus the air nonetheless
both of these drones come in way over
that 250 gram category
the mavic air 2 is about 570 grams
whilst the mavic pro 2
is almost a kilo i think it's grams off
the top of my head
so both drones are well over the maximum
allowed weight limit
for a commercial product without a
commercial license this brings us to
dji's newest drone
produced for this law and for this law
only
it comes in at 249
grams 1 gram under the legal limit it is
the mavic mini 2. now the mavic mini 2
is a very cute little adorable drone and
it isn't exactly
the best thing that you can take on site
because it's this tiny little loud
drone that's just gonna annoy everybody
but having said that it still produces
phenomenal pictures and videos at the
end of the day
especially if you know what you're doing
in lightroom and premiere pro
that you can get away with this drone
being your
only drone in the office and still being
able to produce
incredible footage it has a flight time
of 31 minutes again
even in that small compact package so
still
you have the ability to do absolutely
everything that you could
with the most expensive phantom 4. it
has the same ability to run anywhere
from zero to 40 degrees
so unless you're flying in the snow and
trying to operate it
under conditions that aren't exactly
favorable which would be
relatively nice photos it isn't
recommended
now i say this because i have flown a
mavic 2
air in the freezing freezing cold it was
about -10
and it worked absolutely fine it did
come up with a warning and it just said
be careful be cautious
but i didn't see any issues again i took
this risk
it's completely up to you if you want to
take this risk in that climate
if you're planning on taking really far
away photos and zooming in and cropping
in later
this isn't the drone for you but
obviously as architects again
we're filming most the time just our
project just our finished product
so it's that one house we're relatively
close we have a very controlled
environment
the only elements that are against us is
mother nature
but obviously just make sure you pick a
nice good day to go out and fly a drone
it doesn't matter what drone you select
the laws are basically the same
pick a clear day don't go in the rain
don't go in the dark
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below and because it is
february and we're doing
28 videos in 28 days it would usually be
i'll see you next monday
but because it is february i'll see you
tomorrow